dos grandes grupos de latinos por un
lado están los cubanos y luego los
puertorriqueños que cada uno de ellos
resultan unos 650.000 votantes
registrados en estas elecciones hay
también mucho interés porque políticas
va a impulsar a joe biden cuando llegue
a la casa blanca al frente del gobierno
de eeuu precisamente porque a lo largo
de esta campaña electoral muchos de los
grupos latinos se quejaban de que ni en
los debates ni en las propias campañas
en los actos de campaña se hablaba en
profundidad de aquellos temas que
podrían interesar a la comunidad latina
o incluso de qué relaciones se van a
establecer entre algunos países de
américa latina con eeuu tenemos el caso
de colombia o méxico que son grandes
aliados del gobierno de eeuu y que va a
pasar a partir de ahora como se van a
llevar esas situaciones también
la posición que va a hacer el presidente
electo joe biden cuando llegue a la casa
blanca con el tema de venezuela a pesar
de que él ha dicho que pues va a
incrementar la presión al gobierno de
nicolás maduro